These elderly Swiss women
sued the government for not doing enough to fight climate change
n one almost nine years ago.
In 2016, a group of Swiss women aged 64 and older
formed an organization
to fight for their fundamental right to life and health
in the face of the climate crisis.
In 2020, the group of more than 2,000 women
sued the Swiss government at Europe's highest human rights court
for failing to act to reduce carbon emissions.
The women argue that the governments in action
violated the rights of elderly women
who are particularly impacted by heat waves caused by climate change
due to their age and gender.
On Tuesday, April 9th,
the court ruled in favor of the women,
finding that the Swiss government had failed to comply with his duties
to fight climate change and cut emissions.
This is the first time that a human rights court has ruled that
protecting people from the effects of climate change
is a basic human right.
Switzerland must now revise its climate targets and policy
to take greater action to cut emissions.
The verdict, which cannot be appealed,
also serves as a legal president in Europe
for people to sue their governments over climate inaction.
Swedish climate activist Greta Thunberg
celebrated the victory with the women,
saying it is only the beginning of the journey
towards achieving climate justice.
Speaking after the rolling,
the women said they were not doing this for themselves,
but for the sake of their children.
And their children's children.
Follow for more stories from around the world.